there are three
conclusions the country is facing a deep
democratic institutionality
crisis rooted in interference by the
executive and other public powers
arising from the lack of the rule of law
and leading to great human rights
violations particularly against persons
who speak out publicly against the
government
and deteriorating living conditions for
the population leading to the forced
migration of at least 5.6
million people since 2015 the co-opting
of the judiciary in venezuela by the
executive has contributed to the
institutional crisis having no
nothing that can stop it the
constitutionality and legality of the
actors of the other powers of state is
has been overtaken by the executive and
the judiciary has created new obstacles
to overcoming the crisis the news the
major challenges show the need for
dialogue directed to reestablishing
democratic institutionality and
promoting real effective independence of
the public powers and consolidation of a
system of checks and balances only in
that way can there be reparation for
victims of serious human rights
violations and non-repetition measures
thank you
thank you i give the floor to ethiopia
on zoom
thank you mariam president ethiopia
would like to commend the bolivian
republic of venezuela for its effort to
cooperate with the council and its
mechanisms as well as for successfully
completing to upr reviews
ethiopia is concerned however by the
continued policization of issues at the
human rights council and continued
selective discriminate discriminatory
practice we are of the view that the
selective focus of the council on
certain human rights issues and
institutions such as the resolution
45-20
brought about this interactive dialogue
runs counter productive to the council's
mandate and the global promotion and
protection of all human rights the work
of the council should be guided by
constructive dialogue and cooperation
and not by double standard the
politicization particularly with respect
to country specific initiatives such a
resolution 45 20
will will not
generate the
impact on the ground nor promote
consensus on human rights issues because
it doesn't enjoy the support of the
country concerned this is why ethiopia
reiterates once again that the human
rights agenda must be pursued in a fair
manner in accordance with general
assembly resolution 60
251 that established the human rights
council and with due respect for the
principle of u.n charter such as
national sovereignty territorial
integrity and non-interference in
internal affairs of states i thank you
thank you i give the floor to cambodia
for a video statement
president my delegation takes note of
the report of the special reporter
cambodia maintains that all country
mandates will be established with
consent and cooperation of the country
under review
otherwise such methods not only become
counterproductive but also replace the
council resources
the enduring strength of all human
rights mechanism
lies in even-handed approach with
transparency objectivity and
impossibility as well as in full
adherence to the principle of sovereign
quality respect for territorial
integrity and non-interference which are
well enshrined in the u.n chapter these
principles are also recalled in the
resolution of the human rights council
comedia reaffirms that human rights
agenda must be addressed through a
genuine dialogue based approach with
non-confrontation non-politicization
and non-selectivity based on verified
sources of information and bearing in
mind
the national particularity of each
country can be recognized the goodwill
of the venezuelan government in engaging
with ohchr and your human right
mechanism namely upr and special
reporters i thank you
thank you i give the floor to the lao
people's democratic republic on zoom
thank you madam president
the lao pedia commends the venezuelan
government
for its full support and cooperation to
the work of the oscar in new zealand to
provide technical assistance and
capacity building to venezuela in the
field of human rights
we would like to re-emphasize that the
work of the human rights council
should be guided by the principles of
universality impartiality objectivity
non-selectivity and constructive
dialogue and probation
we also encourage states and jewish and
human rights
conduct general dialogue and cooperation
shared experiences and best practices
and provide technical assistance
according with the needs
and
having a concept of the country
concerned with the view to strengthening
the capacity and ownership of the
government to fulfill its obligation on
the promotion and protection of human
rights i thank you madam president
thank you i give the floor to south
sudan on zoom
thank you madam president
the human rights council can be affected
then we now see
and can get any better result that we
are getting in the efforts into the
promotional protection of the human
rights across the globe
and fulfill the purpose with for which
it came into the beam
i
nation that are struggling to build
their nation and to
to lift up to the
true meaning of keeping up with the
promotion and protection of the human
rights are the ones that are
intentionally discouraged for the reason
best knowing to this concept
we have been thought how to
stand by ourselves and
pass people and
and be on during the pandemic
uh pandemic time
unfortunately unilaterally causing
measures that are being persuaded by
some countries against others have
extremely affected the enjoyment of the
human rights of the people
venezuela should not remain under eye
under resolution for 45 20 that does
reflect to
the spirit of cooperation being expected
by the government and the people of
angela south sudan has this council to
remove resolution
45-20 on venezuela in order to allow the
people of venezuela to enjoy human
rights that their
thank you president
we
wish to
refer to the importance of fulfilling
the relevant resolution for the
protection of human rights which must be
based on cooperation
and strengthen the capacities of states
that so they can fulfill their human
rights obligations universality
objectivity non-selectivity are crucial
in human rights council
and
bolivia does not support country
specific resolutions which are
politically motivated the resolution of
4520 was not achieved by consensus we
call for constructive dialogue and
coordinated work with the concerned
country
we welcome the work of the office of the
high commission
which
points to the work done by venezuela to
fulfill certain resolutions
venezuela has been supporting the work
of the office of the high commissioner
present in the country
under the letter of understanding which
was renewed recently
we
are concerned at the adverse impact of
the unilateral coercive measures which
we condemn
these
harm venezuela's efforts to control a
pandemic
under international
law and international human rights law
this is
the wrong approach and we
wish
to see the mandate
fulfilled to support human rights in a
genuine
constructive way based on the principles
and purposes of the charter thank you
thank you i give the floor to canada on
zoo
thank you madam president canada thanks
the fact-finding mission for their
report and commends their rigorous work
documenting past and ongoing human
rights violations and abuses in
venezuela the fact-finding mission
report substantiates sustained and
severe human rights abuses and
highlights the lack of investigation by
the regime into those abuses or
consequences for perpetrators canada has
grave concerns about human rights
violations occurring in venezuela which
according according to the fact-finding
mission could amount to crimes against
humanity canada condemns the ongoing
impunity and lack of accountability for
perpetrators
canada supports the fact-finding
missions efforts to promote justice for
victims and encourages all parties to
work closely with the fact-finding
mission to provide un special
rapporteurs necessary access to document
the human rights situation in venezuela
and advance justice for victims we are
committed to supporting the people of
venezuela in their effort to reach a
peaceful democratic negotiated solution
to the crisis
question the maduro regime has rushed
the approval of the judiciary revolution
proposing a number of reforms to
investigatory police the military code
of justice victims protection
proceedings code amongst others what are
the views of the fact-finding mission on
this reform and what will be needed to
provide justice truth and reparation to
the victims and their families thank you
madam president
thank you i give the flow to eritrea on
zoom
thank you vice madam president
in this very session this is the second
monday dealing with the same subject
matter in the same country
it goes without saying that it is
punitive in nature and a waste of time
and resource in substance
in fact
the resolution 45-20 was supported by a
minority of the members of the council
is a clear additional example
of the politicized use of the council
and shows lack of necessary momentum
venezuela is an active member of the
council and the international community
and has continuously shown its readiness
to cooperate with the council and office
of the high commissioner
in the context of the covet-19 pandemic
the sponsors of resolution 45-20 are
either authors of the unilateral course
of majors or
those who support the regime of
sanctions to continue causing measures
against venezuela seriously affects
the enjoyment of human rights of the
people and hinders the ability of the
government to protect its nationals from
the perils of the pandemic and the wider
economic challenge
in the above context i would like to ask
the fact-finding mission of their
opinion on the unilateral sanctions as
it continues to negatively affect the
food chain ability of the government to
procure vaccine and other medical
supplies i thank you president
thank you and we will now turn to our
list of speakers for non-government
organizations and i give the floor to
freedom house
15 years old went to a demonstration
state agents would attempt to kneel and
threaten to kill him he tried to flee
and was shot in the head with a firearm
luis guillermo died on august 13 2017
after fighting two months against a
decaying health system and harassment by
state officials her only sought to hide
the evidence
madam president members of the council i
am zulmet espinosa i'm the mother of
luis guillermo espinosa as determined by
the second report of the mission my
son's case and hundreds of venezuelans
victims of human rights violations face
a pattern of structural impunity that
deny access to justice
on fifth june 2017 the investigation
began the autopsy protocol was issued
six months after his death and does not
show the presence of metal splinters
from the projective projectile found in
the tomography in 2018 i presented three
documents the state assigned two
prosecutors offices which in a year and
a half did not carry out any
investigation and there were four
changes of prosecutor in 2020 my case
was transferred to caracas and the
prosecutor was chained three times i
asked the members of this council to be
more convincing in supporting the
mission and all of the mechanisms that i
as a victim and venezuelan
recognized as necessary in order one day
to have the truth and justice needed for
the reconciliation of venezuela my son
and all of those wrongly murdered
deserve justice
thank you i now give the floor to the
latin american foundation
members of the council fund latin once
more expresses concerning the existence
of mechanisms under this council which
far from helping to overcome the
challenges in venezuela in human rights
can
continue to undermine constructive
initiatives which benefit venezuelan
people the fact-finding mission is a
clear example of that
just a few days ago the high
commissioner michelle bachelet informed
the council on progress that has been
made in the country as a result of
dialogue
cooperation and technical assistance
with state institutions however the
fact-finding mission has become a factor
of ongoing disturbance which prevents
the office of the high commissioner
making more rapid progress in the work
done in venezuela and at the same time
uses
scarce resources which could be destined
for
programs in the country we call for the
council the council to focus its efforts
and abandon this type of initiative that
departs markedly from the principles
recognized in the vienna declaration and
programme of action
and the instruments that govern the work
of this council
we support the cooperation between the
office and the government of venezuela
beyond the politically motivated
initiatives that certain
persons are pushing within this council
thank you
thank you i give the floor to united
nations watch
the last report of the independent
fact-finding mission on venezuela showed
what we all know
in venezuela there is no justice
and there is no respect for the law
the chavez maduro regime has moved like
any totalitarian system to subjugate the
justice there is no justice to defend
citizens just to oppress them to make
the regime and his henchmen untouchable
and oppose terror and the most scared
people are those who admit to justice
judges prosecutors officials
independent action keeping with the law
is considered to be a betrayal of the
tyranny
and therefore they turn into instruments
of repression since they are hostages of
the system
the report above all shows the horrors
committed against civilians and military
staff
under the justice system in venezuela
there will be no justice while the
criminal regime continues in power and
the international criminal court needs
to make progress in investigating crimes
against humanity
it is unacceptable that deceptive
negotiations seek to obstruct this
process
i wish to express recognition for the
human rights defenders families members
of victims and the victims themselves
for their courage and dignity and
venezuela there is going to be justice
and the truth will not be hidden
i want to express recognition to all
those who will never accept justice
being negotiated thank you
thank you and i would like to remind all
speakers that this is the human rights
council
and there are views that are often
strongly held but it is important that
speakers use language which is
appropriate to this forum i now give the
floor to amnesty international for a
joint statement
madam president amnesty international on
human rights watch welcome the report by
the fact-finding mission like the
fact-finding mission our organizations
have reported on crimes under
international law and human rights
violations by venezuelan security forces
and armed pro-government groups
including violations of the right to
life physical integrity and freedom the
fact-finding mission identified patterns
of violations and crimes that were part
of a widespread and systematic course of
conduct that it concluded amounted to
crimes against humanity
the office of the prosecutor of the icc
reported that based on available
information it had found a reasonable
basis to believe that crimes against
humanity had been committed it is of
grave concern that there appears no
prospect of an independent investigation
or genuine accountability at national
level as the authorities continue to
enable and promote impunity the report
of this session
highlights how the justice system itself
has been turned against the people of
venezuela and the protection of their
rights how in many cases instead of
protecting the victims authorities
charged with investigating human rights
violations and crimes under
international law or participating in
the repression the international
community must do more to fill this
accountability gap and send a clear
message that the perpetrators of crimes
under international law or be held to
account victims and survivors need a
convincing step towards justice
including support for the work of both
the fact-finding mission and the icc and
the exercise of universal jurisdiction
by other states we urge this council to
continue to follow the situation closely
and follow up on the report's
recommendations we would like to ask the
fact-finding mission how civil society
can better contribute to your important
work thank you
thank you and i give the floor to the
international commission of jurists for
a joint statement
the icj and the
international bar association human
rights institution
welcomed the report of the independent
fact-finding mission and note the urgent
need for accountability for severe human
rights violations in venezuela we
condemn the lack of cooperation of the
venezuelan authorities with the mission
and recall that venezuela as a member of
this council is obliged fully to
cooperate with the mission
we're also concerned that the mission
mentions that there were major delays in
recruiting staff which limited its
capacity for carrying out detailed
investigations on on other violations
that are crucial in terms of
accountability we reiterate the urgent
need for
rapid
independent exhaustive investigations
and prosecutions of severe human rights
violations in venezuela also the role by
carried out by judges prosecuting
prosecutors who are controlled or and
duly influenced by the political
authorities must be investigated in
relation to these violations we condemn
the ongoing undue interference by the
executive and legislature over the
judiciary reflected in the
appointment and removal arbitrarily of
judges of the high court and the
pressure on judges in general violating
the independence of the judiciary
distinguished members of the of the
fact-finding mission could you detail
the adverse effects of on human rights
in venezuela of the lack of the lack of
independence of the judiciary including
a particular persecution and prosecution
of judge affini thank you
thank you i give the floor to the
international federation for human
rights leagues
thank you i speak on behalf of the fidh
and venezuela
from venezuela we reiterate the value of
the work and reports of the mission this
is an approach which is at this time for
us the main restraint on
repetition of severe human rights
violations in our country the work of
international organizations
today is the last hope of victims in
terms of obtaining justice
we believe that the announcements
recently by the venezuelan authorities
regarding investigation of various cases
reported in these documents are not
genuine impunity continues to be
structural in venezuela contributed to
by judges prosecutors
investigation units and even the
ombudsman's office
we call on the members of this council
to follow up acts of intimidation and
reprisals against human rights defenders
victims
and organizations that have worked with
the mission
and demand of the state that it abstain
from these acts and investigate and
punish the perpetrators thank you
thank you i give the floor to advocates
for human rights
madam president the advocates for human
rights welcomes the report of the
independent international fact-finding
mission on the bolivarian republic of
venezuela and echoes the call to end
ongoing gross violations of human rights
and for full accountability for
perpetrators and justice for victims the
advocates provides direct representation
for clients seeking asylum in the united
states our venezuelan clients have
reported many instances of politically
motivated unlawful arrests and attention
one client a peaceful activist was
violently arrested by military police
during a protest and detained for two
days in military headquarters where
military police tortured and
interrogated her another client was
kidnapped by a paramilitary group and
beaten with an encyclopedia while he was
handcuffed and then wrapped in foam and
beaten with a wooden stick victims often
do not report these cases of torture and
other ill treatment because they fear
future threats on their lives and the
lives of their family and friends the
advocates called upon venezuela to
establish independent investigation and
prosecution mechanisms to ensure that
government-affiliated agencies and
paramilitary who are complicit in these
acts are held accountable this means
adopting reforms to ensure the
independence of the security forces from
organized crime to end deep-rooted
associations between official security
forces and paramilitary groups in order
to adequately protect individuals
reporting cases of torture and cruel
inhuman or degrading treatment finally
we call upon venezuela to issue standing
invitations to all special procedures
mandate holders to conduct country
visits thank you
thank you i give the floor to world
organization against torture
[Music]
the humanist crisis in venezuela
arises from impunity which
systematically affects hundreds of
victims suffering in silence the
fact-finding
mission has reasonable grounds to
believe that certain of these
crimes were carried out as part of a
generalized systematic attack
against a civilian population
showing that the judiciary has not acted
as an independent controller
in a study
from 2014 to 2020 we showed that in 92
of cases of summary executions there was
no
formal accusation involved in many cases
there were investigations that took over
five years and they're still underway
and in 30 percent
there is an unjustified delay in
processing necessary procedures such as
autopsy reports and 96 there the
perpetrators have not been detained in
40 percent the
facts were investigated by officials
from the same unit that was involved and
then 80 there were threats against
family members
our organizations
call urgently on this council to urge
the fact-finding mission to continue
following up this
severe impunity in venezuela the reform
of the justice system is urgent thank
you
thank you i give the floor to the
international human rights association
of american minorities
the international human rights
association of american minorities
acknowledges that the venezuelan people
deserve international solidarity and the
assistance of this council to fully
enjoy their civil cultural economic
political and social rights erum
recognizes that human rights are
violated in venezuela and calls on the
venezuelan authorities to take
appropriate action the recent report of
the rapporteur on unilateral courts of
measures identifies problems that are
the direct result of sanctions her
report confirms the findings of the
former independent expert on the
international order whose report was
presented to the council 2018. eram
welcomes the work of the office of the
high commission for human rights in
venezuela especially through the
provision of advisory services and
technical assistance and liaison with
the undp fio double ho and ilo bearing
in mind that venezuela is going through
a crisis caused in part by sanctions
generating hunger
scarcity of medicines and immigration
flows eram notes that certain violations
of civil and political rights also
result from the sanctions erum considers
that the report of the fact-finding
commission fails to take into account
root causes of the problems and believes
that the first step toward improving the
human rights situation in venezuela must
be the lifting of sanctions iran is
concerned about the duplication of
working this council and considers that
coherency demands focusing the council's
efforts on the constructive initiatives
of ohacr in caracas and visits by u.n
rapporteurs
thank you and i give the floor to
hastaoir.org
thank you as we mentioned in march the
situation in venezuela remains critical
the political economic and humanitarian
crisis continues to affect millions of
persons inside and outside of the
country because of many human rights
violations this year
around the world many other tragedies
have occurred and this can cloud the
situation in
venezuela as we have been reporting for
years
although
these
the venezuela situation is less in the
media than in recent months the migra
migration crisis in the regions
hyperinflation show the failure of the
system and we cannot pass over this in
silence when millions of people are
victims of a corrupt government which is
not capable of meeting the most basic
needs of venezuelans
the international community must
continue helping in order to mitigate
the consequences for millions of people
who are suffering and realize that while
there are new situations that need
attention the people of venezuela still
require international support the
international community can and must
help
we call on the human rights council in
geneva
there are few improvements and the
government
is severely repressing anybody who
discusses policies many
allies of maduro are falling from grace
around the world and being prosecuted
but that government remains in power it
must have been the perpetrators must be
investigated judged and sentenced before
the international criminal court
venezuela needs concrete action now
thank you
thank you and this was the last speaker
we could accommodate for this dialogue i
will now give the floor to mr francisco
cox vial for his concluding remarks you
have 11 minutes and 45 seconds
thank you
madam president
and we primero
thief
at the outset we
want to
respond to certain allegations from
venezuela
there is no falsity in the documentation
it was all based
on witness accounts victims
and human rights defenders lawyers
former prosecutors former judges
as
judge abbalini for example and the
methodology is based
on documentation which is legal and
official
the detention orders
resolutions
reports of investigations and judiciary
which we could access
as regards the allegation
of the standard of proof being low this
is the standard of proof that is used
for all fact funding missions and
commissions of inquiry and so
that is the standard that is what we
used
regarding
non-entry to venezuela
and that we're a phantom mission
the
issue is that the information on which
we based our conclusions and the report
that we made was from internal sources
in venezuela people inside venezuela
documents that come from inside
venezuela and all of the information or
the vast majority of it comes from
inside
we should mention that
although we wanted to go to venezuela it
was the government that did not make
that possible
we
did not mention a certain
states have said
including eritrea asked directly
why we did not address the unilateral
coercive measures the sanctions in our
opinion that is not it within our
mandate we are focused on
fundamental human rights violations
and so we did not consider that to be
within
many delegations
asked
about a vision regarding the draft law
presented
following the presentation of our report
on the lack of independence of the
judiciary in venezuela
one of those laws is in line with
addressing certain of the violations
that we noted for example
the excessive use of pretrial detention
prolongation of patrol detention
irregularities
delays and trials and these reforms
paper appear correct
but
as we said in the report itself
it is not only in
latin america but in venezuela there is
an issue with the laws not being applied
and we have to see how this law will be
implemented
that is connected with the question from
his excellency the representative of
germany and others who asked about a
vision
of the
situation
today
a
[Music]
um
thank you
this brings us to the end of the
interactive dialogue i wish to thank the
members of the fact-finding mission for
their participation
we will now take a short break before
the presentation of ohcr's oral update
on the extent of civilian casualties in
the syrian arab republic followed by the
general debate on item four
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
we shall now proceed with the
presentation of ohchr's oral update on
the extent of civilian casualties in the
syrian arab republic pursuant to
resolution 46-22
it is my pleasure to welcome miss
michelle bachelet high commissioner for
human rights to present the oral update
by video message
distinguished president excellencies
resolution
46-22 requested my office to resume its
work on the extent of civilian
casualties in the syrian arab republic
in cooperation with civil society in
order to best assess the number of
people killed as a result of 10 years of
conflict
pursuant to that request the office has
undertaken complex and painstaking work
collating data on the number of and
circumstances in which people have been
killed in the course of this terrible
conflict
my update this afternoon will provide an
overview of the methodologies employed
and the information we have collected to
date but first i want to acknowledge the
tremendous commitment and courage
of all the individuals who have
documented incidents of violence
ensuring that the voices of victims are
heard
that those skill are not forgotten and
that information is available for
accountability
other processes to pursue victims rights
madam president in 2013 and 2014
ochr commissioned three statistical
analysis of documented killings in syria
however the situation in syria in 2014
grew more complex and dangerous which
affected our capacity to maintain the
required standards of quality and
verification and led us to suspend this
work
in our last update on this issue in
august 2014 the office reported that a
total of 101
369 individuals have been killed
in 2019 my office reinforced its
capacity to record civilian casualties
and resume its statistical analysis in
order to include syria in its global
reporting for the sustainable
development goals indicator on
conflict-related deaths sdg indicators
16.
through this work we have produced a
statistical analysis of people killed
this assessment that has encompassed
oclchar's own data
records maintained by civil society
organizations many of them collecting
raw data on the ground as well as
information from the syrian government
which shared records covering part of
the 10 years
before outlining the figures that result
from this work i would like to emphasize
that we followed a strict methodology
our numbers include only those people
identifiable by full name with an
established date of death and who died
in an identified governorate
any information that did not include
these three elements was excluded an
exhaustive review was carried out to
prevent duplicate records
on this basis we have compiled a list of
identified individuals killed in the
conflict in syria between march 2011 and
march 2021
over one in every 13 was a woman
727 women in all
almost 1 in every 13 was a child
12 in 27
126 children to be exact
the greatest number of documented
killings was recorded in the governorate
of aleppo with 51 731 named individuals
killed
other locations with very heavy death
tolls were rural damascus with forty
seven thousand four hundred and eighty
three death
homes with forty thousand nine hundred
eighty six death
it lived with thirty three thousand two
hundred and seventy one death
hama with 31
993 death and tartus which lost 31
369 people
behind each recorded death was a human
being
born free and equal
in dignity and rights we must always
make big simple stories visible
both individually and collectively
because the injustice and horror of each
of those deaths should compel us to
action madam president we assess this
figure
209 as statistically sound
based as it is on rigorous work
but is it not and should be not seen as
a complete number of conflict-related
killings in syria during this period
it indicates a minimum verifiable number
and is certainly an undercount of the
actual number of killings
the records that we have received with
only partial information
and which were therefore excluded from
our analysis
indicate the existence of a wider number
of killings that has yet have not been
fully documented
tragically there are also many other
victims who left behind no witnesses or
documentation as to their death and
whose stories we have not yet been able
to uncover
excellencies my office has begun
processing information on the actors
alleged to have caused a number of
deaths
together with the civilian and
non-civilian status of victims as well
as the cause of death by types of
weaponry
further analysis is essential and will
require more time and resources to
continue this complex work
we have also begun to apply established
statistical estimation techniques to
account for missing data in order to
provide a more complete picture of the
scale of the conflict and its impacts on
sirius
these two will be a longer term efforts
requiring additional resource
documenting the identity of
and circumstances in which people have
died
is key to the effective realization of a
range of fundamental rights to know the
truth to seek accountability and to
pursue effective remedies it can also
facilitate survivors access to education
health care and property
documenting deaths is directly
complementary to efforts to account for
missing people
in the context of syria we have been
assisting families of missing people to
effectively engage with international
human rights mechanisms
given the vast number of missing persons
in syria i restate my call
for the creation of an independent
mechanism with a strong international
mandate
to clarify the fate and whereabouts of
missing people
identify human remains
and provide support to relatives
excellencies today the daily lives of
the syrian people remain scared by
unimaginable suffering
they have endured a decade of conflict
and faced deepening economic crisis as
well as the impacts of covet 19.
extensive destruction of infrastructure
has significantly affected the
realization of essential economic and
social rights
and there is still no end to the
violence they are endured
just last month civilians in and around
era were exposed to intense fighting and
discriminate shelling by government
forces and armed opposition groups
it is incumbent upon us all to listen to
the voices of syrian survivors and
victims
and to the stories of those who have now
fallen silent forever
thank you madam president
i thank you
in accordance with established practice
we will begin by listening to the
delegation of the country concerned
i give the floor to the representative
of the syrian arab republic on zoo
i understand that syria is not in the
room and we will return to them if they
do attend
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
we will now begin the general debate
under agenda item four
before we start i would like to remind
you that all requests for a right of
reply relating to statements delivered
during the general debate will be
accommodated exclusively at the end of
the general debate tomorrow
we will now start with a list of members
of the council
and i give the floor to france on behalf
of a group of countries
madame president mercedes
is
[Music]
thank you and i give the floor to egypt
on behalf of the group of arab states
for a video statement
thank you i now give the floor to
pakistan on behalf of the organization
of islamic cooperation on zoom
madam president
the yc reiterates that the council's
work under this agenda item should be
carried out in full compliance with the
principles of universality
objectivity and impartiality as
enshrined in the ung resolution 60-51
accordingly the council should foster
genuine dialogue and constructive
engagement with the concerned country in
order to better
understand legal context challenges and
peculiarities
in consideration of human rights
situations all basic rights should be
treated on the same footing with the
same emphasis similarly the council must
maintain its credibility by considering
each situation on its human rights merit
we are deeply concerned to see that many
situations which are on the agenda of
both the united nations and the oic have
become blind spots for many members and
observers of this council in deference
to their bilateral interests madam
president though i see urges the council
as the premier international body to
ensure protection of the rights freedoms
and dignity of muslim minorities with
either rising tide of state-sponsored
islamophobia the yc reiterates its
strong condemnation of the widely
documented organized violence against
muslims burka ban curbs on religious
education vandalization of mosques
deliberate ridicule of revered religious
personalities and symbols under the garb
of free speech
the council has a duty to push against
these disturbing trends through taking
meaningful actions
madam president the yc also calls upon
the council to take credible steps to
put an end to the system systematic
sustained and widely recorded human
rights violations and entrenched
impunity in situations of foreign
occupation and protected conflicts
the escalating violence forced
displacement and illegal attempts to
obliterate distinct religious cultural
and demographic identity of muslims in
these situations are a matter of grave
concern for the oic we therefore urge
the council to actively monitor and
report on the human rights conditions
and situations of foreign occupation
disputes and conflicts which are on the
agenda of the united nations and the oic
and on which both organizations have
adopted numerous resolutions i thank you
thank you i now give the flow to
azerbaijan on behalf of the non-aligned
movement
thank you madam president the full
statement on behalf of naam will be
available at extranet
nom reaffirms that human rights issues
must be addressed within the global
context through a constructive
non-confrontational non-politicized
non-selective and dialogue based
approach in a fair and equal manner with
objectivity respect for national
sovereignty and territorial integrity
non-interference and internal affairs of
states impartiality non-selectivity and
transparency as the guiding principles
taking into account the political
historical social religious and cultural
peculiarities of each country
now expresses its deep concern over
proliferation of practice of selective
adoption of country-specific resolutions
in the council which is a tool that
exploits human rights for political
purposes and breaches the principles of
universality objectivity and
non-selectivity in addressing human
rights issues
we encourage the council in the
discussions on human rights to give
adequate attention to issues of poverty
under development marginalization
climate change digital divide
instability foreign occupation and
illegal settlements
damage to the cultural heritage of
countries in situations of foreign
conflict and foreign occupation
and those affected by terrorist acts
that engender social and economic
exclusion and violation of human dignity
and human rights
nom recognizes that states have the
primary responsibility to promote
durable solution for idps in situation
of terrorism and armed conflict
including their voluntary return in
safety and with dignity as well as to
ensure respect protection fulfillment
and restoration of the human rights to
that end we stress the importance of
cooperation among states in a good phase
to provide these solutions
nam also recognizes the importance of
post-conflict rehabilitation
reconstruction and reintegration efforts
to sustain peace foster economic
development and promote cooperation and
in this regard highlights the importance
of effective mine action and the role of
international assistance to non-member
states most affected by mines and other
unexploded devices i thank you
thank you i give the floor to venezuela
on behalf of a group of countries for a
video statement
thank you madam president i have the
order to deliver this statement on
behalf of the like-minded group the list
of countries will be published on the
extranet
as a basic principle our countries
reiterate the recombination of the
violation of human rights and
fundamental freedoms in any part of the
world and any situation that constitutes
a serious obstacle to their full
enjoyment
the like-minded group opposes and
rejects politically motivated
country-specific resolutions and
expresses its concern over this
continued selective and discriminatory
practice
we believe that this practice violates
the principles of universality
impartiality objectivity non-selectivity
non-politicization and constitutes
double standards in addressing human
rights issues
we also express our concern over the
proliferation of naming and shaming
which aims to interfere in states
internal affairs violating the universal
principles set forth in the shattered of
the united nations
in this context we are concerned about
the increasing politicization
in the debates taking place under item 4
of the council's agenda which are far
from addressing human rights situations
that require its attention for which it
was conceived
we emphasize the importance of the
universal periodic review as the
fundamental mechanism of the united
nations to address all u.n member
countries human rights issues based on
the sovereign equality of states
cooperation and constructive dialogue
which has proven its full effectiveness
finally the lmg countries recognized the
human rights council as the natural
forum for debating human rights issues
in this regard the like-minded group
opposes the debate of human rights
issues in the u.n security council
including the human rights situation on
specific countries
we call on the member states of the
human rights council and the office of
the high commissioner to continue to
encourage constructive dialogue and
cooperation with all governments
following their national priorities
avoiding the practice of politicization
selectivity and double standards in the
work of the human rights council as well
as of the office i think
thank you i give the floor to pakistan
on behalf of a group of countries
thank you madam i have the honor to
deliver this joint statement on behalf
of some 65 countries respect for
sovereignty independence and territorial
integrity of states and non-interference
in internal affairs of sovereign states
represent basic norms governing
international relations
hong kong xinjiang and tibet related
issues are china's internal affairs that
broke
no external
interference by any external forces we
support china's implementation of one
country two systems in the hong kong
special administrative region
we maintain that all parties should
abide by the purposes and the principles
of the u.n charter
and the principles of impartiality
objectivity and non-selectivity respect
the right of the people of each state to
choose independently the path for human
rights development in accordance with
their national conditions and treat all
human rights with the same emphasis
we call upon all states to uphold
multilateralism solidarity and
collaboration and to promote and protect
human rights through constructive
dialogue and cooperation
we firmly oppose criticization of human
rights and double standards we also
oppose unfounded allegations against
china out of political motivation and
based on this information and
interference in china's internal affairs
under the pretext of human rights i
thank you
thank you i now give the floor to china
on behalf of a group of countries for a
video statement
[Music]
is
thank you i now give the flow to
azerbaijan on behalf of a group of
countries
madam president i have the honor to
deliver this statement on behalf of the
cross regional group of countries full
version of the statement will be
uploaded
to the extranet
the landmines continue to pose a serious
threat to human life security and
humanitarian efforts they affect many
countries around the world by having
enormous impact on civilian population
they hinder activities and threaten
lives of personnel participating in
humanitarian peacekeeping and clearance
programs and operations undermine peace
security and stability of states and
impede sustainable development and peace
building these weapons do not
discriminate between civilians and
combatants and violate people's
fundamental right to life
they breach social economic and cultural
rights for years
vulnerable groups are among those
suffering the most while children
constitute almost half of the victims
we recognize the importance of
comprehensive approach to mind action
victim assistance is a core component of
mind action
in addition to overcoming physical
trauma
mind survivors struggle to achieve
social acceptance gain meaningful
employment and ensure that their rights
are respected
environmental impact of the landmines is
worrisome
they kill and name large numbers of
specimens of wildlife lead to
environmental degradation and large
tracts of mine and cannot be cultivated
and remain uninhabitable
the ongoing kovid 19 pandemic has only
added more burden and requires
additional resources for mind action
in that context enhancing regional and
international cooperation
and greater interagency coherence within
the united nations system on mine action
becomes more urgent international
community shares a commitment to ending
human rights violation and abuses
related to the use of landmines we urge
all u.n member states as well as united
nations system and relevant
organizations to support mine affected
states upon their request by providing
assistance to them in accordance with
international law as soon as possible
thank you
thank you and i advise all delegations
that the list of speakers is now closed
i now give the floor to china on behalf
of a group of countries for a video
statement
madam president
i have the honor to speak on behalf of a
group of countries
we are deeply concerned about the human
rights situation in the united kingdom
systemic racism and racial
discrimination are deep rooted in the uk
hate speech xenophobia and relevant
violence are increasingly exacerbated
the living conditions of minorities
continue to deteriorate
the uk has serious poverty with one
third of families that have children
under the age of five living in poverty
the uk has frequently conducted military
interventions in other countries
causing numerous casualties of civilians
and undermining the economic and social
development in the country is concerned
the british military personnel committed
serious crimes in their overseas
military operations
by arbitrarily killing innocent
civilians
and conducted torture
but the perpetrators have been shielded
by the uk government
the uk imposes unilateral cohesive
measures arbitrarily
severely infringing on the human rights
of the people in the country is
concerned
turning a blind eye to its human rights
violations and indulged in the mentality
of canolaism
the uk is obsessed with fabricating and
spreading this information
pointing fingers at others
and infringing in others internal
affairs to serve its own political
agenda
we urge the uk to face up to its
problems
put an end to all human rights
violations
and stop using human rights as a
political tool
we call on the human rights council and
relevant special procedures
to look into human rights violations in
the uk
and take necessary steps to monitor
actions of the uk government to correct
his mistakes
thank you madam president
thank you
i now give the floor to germany for a
video statement
madam president in afghanistan we call
on the taliban appointed caretaker
cabinet to respect human rights
including women's and girls rights
in belarus violence and repression
against opposition in civil society must
end now
justice for the perpetrators must be
served democratic reforms and new free
and fair elections must be realized
we condemn the political
instrumentalization of migrants and
refugees by the lukashenka regime
in china we are gravely concerned about
systematic human rights violations
especially against ethnic minorities in
xinjiang and tibet
the high commissioner must be granted
unfettered access to xinjiang we welcome
her announcement to present her findings
to date and encourage an early
publication
in sar hong kong we are gravely
concerned about the application of the
national security law
we deplore a trend towards less respect
of human rights less pluralism and an
erosion of democratic principles
in egypt we condemn the continued
application of the death penalty
civil society organizations must be able
to work freely and independently we
welcome the priority given to the
universality of human rights in the new
national human rights strategy
its comprehensive implementation is key
in iran violations of women's rights the
right to freedom expression and assembly
persists we strongly condemn detention
conditions in iran's continued use of
the death penalty including against
juvenile offenders
in myanmar the human rights and
humanitarian situation deteriorates
we call for the immediate release of
those arbitrarily detained
in russia the deterioration of the human
rights situation continues
the recently tightened ngo legislation
and extremism charges are misused to
outlaw opposition and human rights
defenders exacerbated by the lack of
access to fair trials
we call for the release of all political
prisoners and of those arrested for
their religious beliefs
in the illegally annexed autonomous
republic of crimea and the city of
sevastopol as well as in those areas of
eastern ukraine currently not under the
control of the ukrainian government
we call on russia to immediately stop
systematic human rights violations
thank you madam president
thank you
i now give the floor to armenia for a
video statement
president
armenia derose of attention of his
esteemed council to a violation of the
human rights of a population of a
republic of armenia living in close
vicinity to the international border
with azerbaijan
ever since may 2021 the armed forces of
azerbaijan have been trying to occupy
new military outposts and positions
encroaching on the sovereign territory
of armenia and targeting both armenian
servicemen and civilians
azerbaijani air forces periodically open
sporadic and indiscriminate fire in the
direction of armenian border towns and
villages
resort to the cattle fifth and employ
our ways of intimidation thus preventing
the population from the right to freely
use their pastures
and our serious loves of concern are the
repeated cases of arson by the
azerbaijani armed forces which so far
crippled more than 300 hectares of
pastures and 150 hectares of grasslands
seriously reflecting affecting the
livelihood of the local armenian farmers
since august 2021 where azerbaijani
servicemen have been regularly blocking
the motorway but connects the armenians
northern regions to the southern ones
and further continues to neighboring
iran
it grossly violates the right of a free
movement of the civilian population
severe their access to food and medical
services
this is how azerbaijan interprets its
own commitment on opening all
communications in the region
notably such instigations are taking
place against a backdrop of excessive
use of anti-armenian hate speech open
friends to youth force justification
over continued military provocations and
the incitement of territorial claims
against the republic of
these human armenia
violations come to supplement the abuses
that other belgium perpetuates in the
context of a nagorno-karabakh conflict
exacerbating the woods over recent and
preceding wars
we believe that this situation requires
closer attention of east august council
its member and observer states and the
u.n human rights machinery i thank you
thank you i now give the floor to
venezuela for a video statement
is
[Music]
thank you i give the floor to japan for
a video statement
japan is concerned about the continuing
serious human rights and humanitarian
situations in various parts of the world
with regard to the situation in
afghanistan japan urges all parties to
ensure the safe movement of those who
wish to leave the country
protect the lives and property of all
afghans
restore
a social order and protect and enhance
basic human rights especially the rights
of women
we further urge all parties to build a
country where an inclusive political
process that includes diverse ethnic and
sectarian groups
is ensured
we are closely watching the actual
actions of the taliban
with regard to the asia-pacific region
in the shadow of remarkable economic
development challenges remain for
democratization and the protection of
basic human rights
as for the situation in myanmar since
the coup japan has consistently and
strongly urged the national military to
immediately stop the violence
release the detainees and restore the
democratic government as soon as
possible
we have also directly conveyed our
concerns regarding the decision to
invalidate the results of the election
last year
we are further seriously concerned about
the recent situation in xinjiang and
hong kong as are the other member states
as for the issue of abductions by the
dprk as the families of the victims are
now advancing age
there is no time to lose in resolving
this issue
japan counts on the understanding and
cooperation of the international
community
for the resolution of this issue i thank
you
thank you i now give the floor to the
republic of korea for a video statement
thank you madam president
more than a decade into conflict as of
today the human rights situation in
syria remains deeply concerning
in particular the republic of korea is
increasingly concerned over the recent
escalation in armed hostilities in the
northwest region and the city-like
situation in dara al-balad
we are alarmed by the indiscriminate
shelling and airstrikes that have caused
numerous civilian casualties as well as
the destruction of civilian
infrastructure
given these devastating consequences my
delegation urges all parties to end
violence immediately and comply with
their obligations
under the international human rights and
humanitarian role
safe and unhindered humanitarian access
must be granted to all affected areas
on burundi while recognizing the several
positive steps by the burundian
government
we
remain concerned about the report that
serious human rights violations have
continued to be committed notably
targeted killing enforced disappearance
and torture we call on the government of
burundi to ensure that each agent
respect human rights and hold those
responsible accountable
as
is at a critical moment in shaping its
structural reform we encourage the
government to engage with the u.n human
rights mechanisms
including by reopening the ohchr country
or peace madam president there is an
increasing concern on the distressing
trend of intensifying restrictions on
the human rights community and the
shrinking democratic space in belarus
there has been a worrisome report
recently on the increased crackdowns on
civil society such as race
and detention against human rights
activists as well as the short down of
multiple civil society organizations
such intimidation must be stopped and
civic space must be protected i thank
you
thank you i now give the floor to
indonesia on zoo
madam president
indonesia attached his great importance
to the calls made at this august council
to direct actions towards concrete and
meaningful human rights protection and
promotion on the ground
the action to enable effective work of
the u.n system should indeed be directed
at supporting member states in promoting
protecting and fulfilling the human
rights of their people
the council must show itself as a
credible and enabling platform for
constructive dialogue and cooperation
therefore indonesia retreats at the
principles of universality objectivity
and impartiality as enshrined in
president 60-251
must continue to direct the council's
work under this agenda item
in consideration of human rights
situations all basic civil political
social economic and cultural rights
especially the right to development
should be treated equally
furthermore respect for the sovereignty
and territorial integrity of all states
must continue to be observed
unequivocally
madame president
the kovic 19 pandemic has expressed
exposed systemic gaps in many areas of
human rights widening inequalities in
almost all walks of life
indonesia notes with concern a number of
foreign trends that requires the
council's heightened attention among
others vaccine nationalism and the
inequitable distribution of vaccines
racism xenophobia and intolerance
undebated hate speech and incitement
under the guise of freedom of
expression and the continued denial of
human rights in many places in the world
particularly in occupied palestinian
territory
being the most pressing global issue at
the moment tackling the pandemic
together and building back better should
be at the top of the council's
priorities including any countries
considered under this agenda item to do
this the council must first promote
greater solidarity and political
commitment towards guaranteeing the
right to health for all including by
ensuring equitable access to vaccines
and second promote greater protection
towards all people disproportionately
affected by kovic 19.
this includes affording greater
protection and acknowledgement for
health workers as human rights defenders
and protecting the rights of vulnerable
groups
indonesia will continue to support the
collective efforts of the council's
exercises mandate to give adequate
attention to the aforementioned issues
while calling upon all states to refrain
from using the council as a vehicle for
narrow-minded political aspirations i
thank you
thank you i give the floor to austria
for a video statement
thank you austria fully aligns itself
with a statement by france on behalf of
26 eu member states on the human rights
situation in belarus and myanmar we
refer to our statement under the
respective interactive dialogues the
situation in afghanistan is of great
concern civil society leaders human
rights defenders journalists and members
of the judiciary are increasingly
targeted any retaliation against those
who have supported the building of a
democratic afghanistan based on the rule
of law and human rights is unacceptable
we're particularly concerned about
afghan women and girls their respective
rights to education work freedom of
movement and their protection from all
forms of violence we stress the need for
full investigations into reports of
human rights violations the taliban will
be judged not by their words but by
their actions we welcome the increased
willingness of burundi to engage in
international dialogue to address the
country's direct human rights record
however human rights violations persist
in the climate of growing insecurity
authorities have also doubled down
repression against human rights
defenders and journalists perceived to
be critical of the government we urge
for rooney to reopen civic space by
creating a safe environment for human
rights defenders journalists civil
society and supporters of the opposition
more than 10 years after the start of
the conflict the human rights suffering
in syria continues tens of thousands of
people including children are missing or
arbitrarily detained often subjected to
sexual violence or other forms of
torture the perpetrators need to be held
to account austria therefore re states
that the security council should refer
the situation in syria to the icc we
also echoed the call by
coi to all parties of the conflict to
cease attacks on civilians including
indiscriminate airstrikes in shelling
and to pursue a nationwide ceasefire in
line with security council resolution
we're very concerned about the
widespread and systematic human rights
violations committed in venezuela
including arbitrary detentions
extrajudicial killings torture rape and
other forms of sexual violence we fully
support the mandate of the ffm to
document these violations were
encouraged by recent positive signals
such as the beginning of venezuelan
negotiations in mexico but would like to
stress that the only way out of this
crisis is the resumption of a political
dialogue leading to credible inclusive
and transparent elections i thank you
thank you i give the floor to the
netherlands for a video statement
the kingdom of the netherlands aligns
itself with a statement delivered by
france on behalf of 26 countries member
states of the european union
members of the human rights council
should strive to make progress in the
protection of all human rights we recall
and underline the responsibilities that
come with the membership of this council
in china we remain seriously concerned
about the human rights situation in
xinjiang and tibet and the restrictions
on press freedom and the freedom of
religion and belief
we regret lack of progress in granting
immediate meaningful and unfettered
access for ohr to xinyam and look
forward to oh
assessment of the situation
furthermore we remain concerned about
the implementation of the national
security law in hong kong we reiterate
concerns over continuous shrinking civic
space and independent voices across
russia
including measures constraining the work
of ngos independent media and
individuals and including legislation on
foreign agents
we call on russia to thoroughly
investigate reports of grave human
rights violations and the persecution of
lgbti persons including interchania
we remain gravely concerned about the
human rights violations in eritrea
where civilians are detained without
trial press freedom is absent and a
mandatory national service continues to
be enforced we also condemn the presence
of eritrean troops in northern ethiopia
and the alleged human rights violations
they commit
we remain concerned about a human rights
situation in cuba after the july protest
where thousands of cuban citizens called
for freedom and rights repression by the
cuban authorities intensified we call on
the cuban government to release those
arbitrarily detained to engage in an
all-inclusive dialogue and to respect
the human rights of its citizens
membership of this council is not a free
right
madam president in this context we
recall our plea for a formal candidate
pledging event for future human rights
council candidates in the unga alongside
the existing and valuable ngo led event
thank you
thank you i give the floor to cuba on
zoom
[Music]
a
thank you i now give the floor to the
russian federation for a video statement
thank you i now give the floor to india
for a video statement
15 years have passed since the
establishment of the human rights
council
it is time for us to assess his
achievements reflect on its failures
to strengthen and reform it so as to
enable it to achieve the objectives for
which it has been set up
the council has been emphasized as a
platform for providing impetus to
international cooperation and
collaboration for realization of the
global goal of global promotion and
protection of all human rights for all
it has not been successful in achieving
this goal in full measure
enjoyment of human rights by people
globally has faced challenges such as
terrorism and violent extremism climate
change and lack of sustainable
especially those in vulnerable
situations
while functioning in such a challenging
environment the discourse within the
council has been politicized and
polarized
there is a lack of commitment to making
consensus and the council has a lot of
resolutions with the support of less
than 50 percent of its member states
the council needs to function in a
constructive non-confrontational
situation in a few
countries in the council under the
second item have been
unproductive to the realization of the
votes
the council should focus on creating
environment both at the national and
global levels under which states are
encouraged
to fulfill their human life obligations
we believe that enhancement of capacity
through technical assistance
and with the consent of the state
concern is the best way towards
improving human rights situation
it is important that while technical
assistance and capacity the priority is
according to implementation of accepted
rupiah recommendations i thank you madam
president thank you i now give the floor
to china for a video statement
foreign
the
you i now give the floor to the czech
republic for a video statement
statement by eu member states we are
concerned about the series of mandates
violations in belarus the regime
continues to escalate its attacks
against the opposition reminds offenders
independent journalists and activists
more than 650
political prisoners are being detained
arbitrarily and suffer from serious ill
treatment including torture we call for
their immediate unconditional release
including maria karis nicola and maxim
zlack
all human rights violations must be
investigated in russia civil society
human rights defenders and independent
media continue to be targeted we condemn
the practice of shutting off websites we
repeat our call for the release of
alexey navalny we expect russia to
comply with the ruling of the european
court of human rights it is concerning
that the osce was not able to observe
the elections to the duma they were
neither free nor fair
continued revelations of human rights in
venezuela remain a source of great
concern for us we condemn the
persecution of the opposition and
attacks against media and civil society
the humanitarian situation is very
concerning holding of free and inclusive
elections is essential
we are deeply concerned about this
recent violence in afghanistan including
summary and extrajudicial
executions it is crucial to ensure
accountability we are concerned about
the afghan women and girls and we
condemn all form of violence against
them they deserve to live in safety
security and dignity their rights must
be safeguarded and they must be able to
pass faithfully in the political process
and society
we strongly condemn attacks by military
contagious the people of myanmar acts
amounting to crimes against humanity we
call on the kunda to stop the violence
and cease the prosecution of journalists
lawyers and human rights defenders those
arbitrarily detained must be released we
are concerned about reports of an upward
trend of gender-based violence
we are also worried about the ongoing
conflict in degree and autumn ethiopia
we call on all parties to end the
violence ensure a safe humanitarian
access and enter a process of peaceful
dialogue and reconciliation
we continue to be concerned about the
situation in syria and its impact on the
civilian population we strongly condemn
the cross humanized relations including
crimes against humanity committed in the
dprk on the direct supervision of the
state authorities
thank you i now give the floor to
denmark for a video statement
i'm sorry i'm not getting any sound on
this video
i now give the floor to pakistan on zoom
we will come back to denmark
thank you madam president
pakistan believes that dialogue and
constructive engagement with the country
concerned provides the preferred tools
to address human rights concerns the
council should pay special attention to
the human rights conditions in the u.n
recognized situations of foreign
occupation given the occupation regimes
irresponsible behavior
and willful defiance of international
law therefore the imperative of global
accountability in such situations
remains invariably pressing pakistan
invites the council's urgent retention
towards grave situation in the occupied
jammu and kashmir where india has
violated international law defied u.n
security council resolutions and flouted
the 4th geneva convention particularly
since 5th august 2019.
during the last two years undeterred by
global censure india is pursuing an
increasing intensity a colonization
project the parallels of which are
difficult to find in modern history
india maliciously wants to transform the
majority indigenous kashmiris into a
minority population and deprive them of
their inalienable right to of
self-determination
india continues to deny access to ohchr
un special procedures civil society
international media
for independent investigation for its
system systematic violations in occupied
kashmir this month pakistan has
presented a dossier containing concrete
evidence regarding india's widespread
human rights transgressions graduating
to crimes against humanity and war
crimes in order to cover up its
atrocities india continues to concoct
false linkages between kashmiri freedom
movement and global terrorism
the u.n experts have publicly warned
about the devastating human rights
impact of india's demographic
engineering of the disputed territory
and appeal to the world community to
step up we therefore call on the
international community we do therefore
call on the council to implement the
recommendations addressed to it in two
kashmir reports and institute a
commission of inquiry for investigating
india's human rights crimes in occupied
kashmir in exercise of her prevention
mandate we also urge the high
commissioner to continue monitoring and
reporting on jammu and kashmir and ask
india to give her office access to
occupied territory
there is growing human cost of from of
appeasement and political expediency we
express hope that champions of global
human rights would come forward in
shaping hrc's credible response on jammu
and kashmir i thank you
thank you i now give the floor to sudhan
for a video statement
i'm sorry i'm not getting sound on this
video
we will move on to ukraine i give the
floor to ukraine also for a video
statement to see if we fare better
unfortunately we're not getting any
sound on the video statement made by
ukraine i now give the floor to
philippines on zoom
all concerned we have consistently
called for the console to reorient its
approach along the following lines
is the role of non-state actors in the
dynamics of complex human rights
situations in different settings while
states or duty bearers are the best
often
the explanation rights in international
humanitarian law increasingly occurs at
the horizontal space between non-state
actors and civic actors and rights
holders
the philippines has repeatedly mentioned
the example of the cpp npa ndf in the
way its front organizations have
obscured and misrepresented facts to
escape accounts
due diligence uh processes that enable
coordination and dialogue between and
among the council ohchr and the state
subject of our attention
our debates and processes must observe
the highest standards of objectivity and
be guided by methodologies that are
transparent inclusive and fair to uphold
the dignity and vitality of the human
rights pillar our discourse must go
through the noise and sex decision seek
decisions that are informed by facts in
the complexity of the situation to
address
lastly to focus our attention measures
that bring about positive concrete and
long-term change in subject
as opposed to an indiscriminate cycle of
unilateral actions that tend to entrench
patients in the council and squander the
already stretched resources of the ohchr
we have called for the council to
examine more responsibly the cost of our
action this adidas impact on the ground
and to never forgetting our
and where the money is going the
constant is aware that the philippines
launched the first ever national level
you enjoying program on human rights
targeting specific areas for capacity
building and technical cooperation this
stance is an effective cooperation that
generates long-lasting changes
complementary to the national rights and
development agenda i thank you i'm
president
thank you and i understand the video
statement of denmark may now be played
with sound i give the floor to denmark
denmark refers to the statement
delivered on behalf of 26 member states
of the european union as well as
to our nordic baltic statements under
the interactive dialogues on belarus
ethiopia tigre myanmar syria
libya ukraine yemen burundi and south
sudan
we recall our concern for the human
rights situation in afghanistan as
reflected in our statement under the
item 2 general debate
with respect to china we continue to be
deeply concerned about reports of human
rights violations in xinjiang and tibet
we reiterate our call on china to allow
meaningful access to xinjiang for the
human rights commission and other
independent observers
arrests imprisonment and long-term
detention of civil society activists and
human rights defenders in the islamic
republic of iran
is of great concern
we call for
fair trials and proper conditions for
prisoners recognizing reform initiatives
in the kingdom of saudi arabia
implementation is key
and the persecution of civil society
activists is deeply worrying we also
note with concern the use of torture and
death penalty in both countries
we strongly oppose israel's illegal
expansion of settlements in the opt
including evictions of palestinians from
their homes in east jerusalem we urge
the palestinian authority to respect the
right
to freedom of expression and to peaceful
association and assembly
while recognizing egypt's role in
regional security and the fight against
terrorism we are continuously concerned
by the human rights situation in the in
and in particular
the shrinking space for civil society
finally we reiterate uh our call for the
release of arbitrarily detained persons
in bahrain including the danish bahraini
citizen mr
al-qaeda imprisoned for 10 years
and a victim of torture who needs
treatment and rehabilitation thank you
thank you and i now give the floor to
sudhan for a video statement
thank you i now give the floor to
ukraine for a video statement
madam president vice presidents ukraine
expresses its deep concern regarding the
human rights situation in venezuela
burundi myanmar gpr
south sudan syria nicaragua and the
russian federation on which i would like
to specifically elaborate
the situation in russia really requires
serious council's attention under agenda
item 4.
russia greatly violates human rights and
fundamental freedoms of its citizens by
restricting their civil political and
cultural space brutally suppressing
peaceful political protests killing or
imprisoning opposition leaders
encouraging the rights of ethnic
religious and other minorities etc
journalists have continued to be subject
to arrest imprisonment physical attacks
harassment and intimidation for their
reporting
the recent state doom elections have
been marked by the russian government's
interference and manipulation of the
electoral process including the
inclusion of meaningful opposition
candidates
organization and holding of the russia's
elections on the churches of ukraine
temporarily occupied by the russian
federation in the autonomous republic of
crimea and certain areas of donetsk and
luhansk regions represents a serious
relation of ukraine's sovereignty
territorial integrity and international
law the results of these elections on
the temporary occupied churches will be
null and void and thus the russian state
duma will be formed with violation of
international law and its
representatives will be considered
illegitimate
we wish to recall the un-general
assembly resolution 75-192
the situation of human rights in the
autonomous republic of crimea ukraine
which condemns all attempts by russia to
legitimacy legitimize or normalize its
attempted annexation of crimea including
automatic imposition of russian
citizenship illegal election campaigns
in voting change of the democratic
structure of the population of crimea
and suppression of national identity
ukraine appeals to the human rights
council and the office of the high
commissioner to give proper assessment
of the continued serious violations of
human rights and international
humanitarian law by the russian
federation in the temporarily occupied
territories of ukraine i thank you
thank you i give the floor to the united
kingdom for a video statement
thank you madam president
let me start with china
we remain seriously concerned about
systematic human rights violations in
xinjiang
the evidence is compelling and
far-reaching
u.n experts must have immediate and
unfettered access to xinjiang and we
share the high commissioner's regret
that she has not been granted access to
date and we welcome her plans for an
assessment of the available information
later this year
we condemn the military coup in myanmar
and we call on the military junta to
return power to the democratically
elected government and end its serious
human rights violations
the human rights picture in south sudan
remains deeply worrying particularly
given government attempts to stifle
peaceful protest
the commission on human rights remains a
necessary mandate
russia must uphold the human rights of
all including the right to freedom of
expression and the right to free
elections the russian authorities
measures to marginalize civil society
silence independent media and prevent
independent opposition candidates from
participating in the state domain
elections undermine political plurality
and disregard russia's international
commitments
syrians continue to suffer horrific
human rights violations and risk being
killed by the regime and its allies
there must be accountability for victims
and perpetrators must face justice
we thank the htc atr for its important
reporting on civilian casualties
stark increase in executions in egypt is
alarming we call on egypt to cease use
of the death penalty and we are deeply
concerned by terrorism charges against
germanness and activists by asset
freezes and travel bans on human rights
defenders
welcome steps by the government of
burundi that demonstrate greater
commitment to human rights
international monitoring of the
situation should continue and we call on
burundi to cooperate with all un human
rights mechanisms finally the uk has
raised his concerns about afghanistan
tigray venezuela and belarus in other
statements thank you
thank you and i now give the floor to
uruguay for a video statement
is
[Music]
thank you i now give the floor to
uzbekistan for a video statement
[Music]
is
thank you i now give the floor to cote
d'ivoire on zoo
madame
foreign
[Music]
thank you i now give the floor to france
foreign
thank you and we will now proceed with
the list of observer states and i give
the floor to liechtenstein on behalf of
a group of countries for a video
statement
i have the honor of delivering this
statement on behalf of a core group on
casualty recording
we thank as a group the high
commissioner for oral update on the
extent of casualties in the syrian arab
republic our group has consistently
reiterated that casualty recording in
situations of armed violence and
conflict upholds fundamental human
values by endeavoring to produce a
comprehensive and detailed record of
every person killed and the
circumstances of their death
among armed conflicts the war in syria
has been one of the deadliest with
several hundred thousands of civilians
killed and around a hundred thousand
still missing casualty records recognize
the value of every individual human life
and the unique loss which each death
represents thus recognizing the inherent
dignity of every person affected their
right to life and families and survivors
right to truth and accountability the
work of the office of the high
commissioner for human rights on
conflict-related casualties in syria is
of crucial importance to show different
levels of violence conflict hot spots at
different times circumstances of death
actors involved weapons used and further
information that can be used for
accountability memorialization remedies
and policy decisions we understand this
is only a basis for further work and
analysis and would like to express our
strong support for the continuation of
the ohchr's work in this regard i thank
you
thank you and i give the floor to
luxembourg for a video statement
[Music]
thank you i give the floor to israel for
a video statement
thank you madam president israel remains
deeply concerned about the situation of
human rights in iran including the
widespread use of death penalty in 2020
alone 267 people including nine women
were executed and today over 80 child
defenders are on death row we are also
deeply concerned that the iranian
government frequently imposes these test
sentences based on forced confessions
extracted through torture or other
unfair trials
madam president last month the world was
alarmed to see leaked footage from
having prison showing prisoners living
in inhumane conditions and being
subjected to horrific beatings
this prison isn't famous for its human
rights abuses against innocent
protesters and human rights offenders
it's also there that the iranian regime
holds hostage innocent individual used
to pressure
other governments
we are deeply alarmed by these abuses
inside iran and how the iranian regime
exports these practices through its
armed forces and its proxies to other
parts of the region madam president the
council must urgently address the human
rights abuses committed both in iran and
by its proxies in the region there will
never be stability in syria there will
never be prosperity in lebanon and there
will never be peace in yemen if the
world does not address iran's malign
activities in the middle east and beyond
i thank you
thank you and i give the floor to
australia for a video statement
and about the human rights and
humanitarian crisis unfolding in
afghanistan we call on the taliban to
allow safe passage for citizens and visa
holders and to allow unimpeded access
for all humanitarian workers
we will judge the taliban by their
actions and call on them to uphold human
rights cease violence and ensure
terrorism does not find a home in
afghanistan australia is alarmed by
violations and abuses of human rights
and violations of international
humanitarian law in the dprk syria yemen
and ethiopia we call on relevant parties
to protect respect and promote human
rights
we continue to hold grave concerns about
numerous and credible reports of human
rights violations and abuses against
uighurs and other muslim ethnic
minorities in xinjiang including
restrictions on freedom of religion
large-scale extrajudicial detention mass
surveillance forced labour and forced
birth control including forced
sterilization australia again calls on
china to allow urgent unfettered access
to xinjiang for the high commissioner
we condemn the horrific violence and
high death toll in myanmar we call on
the regime to refrain from further
violence and immediately implement its
commitments under the asean five-point
consensus
australia welcomes the venezuela-led
negotiations in mexico we remain deeply
concerned by the political economic and
humanitarian situation in venezuela
participation from all stakeholders is
essential for a peaceful solution to the
crisis
thank you
and this was the last speaker that we
could accommodate at this meeting
excellencies ladies and gentlemen this
brings us to the end of today's public
meeting we will resume the 20th meeting
in a closed meeting in relation to the
complaint procedure of the human rights
council i will therefore suspend this
meeting for a few minutes to allow all
members of the council to come to room
20 and we will resume our public meeting
on monday at 10 am to continue the
general debate under item 4.
you